Welcome back, everyone it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Avengers infinity saga
Marvel rewatch video.
There were all kinds of marble phase for big
Easter eggs setting up Avengers endgame in
the Marvel phase for movies that we didn't
spot the first time we saw the movie we'll
break everything down were also doing the
infinity saga box set giveaway for all the
movies also be naming a winner during this
video for the first box set I got to the giveaway
all you have to do to enter that is just be
a subscriber and leave your favorite moment
from the Avengers movie on the video careful
for spoilers for all the Marvel movies so
far in all just number these as we go along
is because there's so many Easter eggs starting
at the beginning the movie literally starts
with the title sequence revealing itself inside
the Tesseract framing what the entire infinity
saga of movies is going to be about the infinity
stones themselves at the time there a lot
of fan theory is that the space stone was
inside the Tesseract, but that wasn't confirmed
by Marvel till years later.
For those that remember the epic Santos name
theory of the stones the voiceover during
that scene might sound like a evil version
of Benedict Cumberbatch doing a Doctor strange
voice, but the character is actually named
the other he Santos's servant who also comes
back to be killed by Ronan during guarding
to the galaxy.
He's played by Alexi Dennis off from the weed
verse there a lot of other weed verse alumni
that appeared during the Avengers and other
Marvel movies throughout the MCU the character
of the other is the one who serves as the
go-between for Loki and Santos and sanctuary
where Loki seeks an alliance with him is a
path to revenge on earth.
So when they bicker later in the movie and
Loki shows up looking like is halved at the
beginning of the film.
It's the other who tortured him into submission
for the Enos this is actually touch Loki himself
for the first time until Avengers infinity
war when he touches him to kill him, and as
you notice here Santos's rocking chair is
also very different looking from the one we
saw on guardians, the actor who plays Santos
is also very different person in his visual
design is very different.
The reason is character model look so different
is because they hadn't cast Josh Brolin to
actually speak lines of dialogue is the Enos
yet in this is a very early template for what
Santos would become Damien Poitier is the
person playing him here.
He's actually talked about later.
He said it was a pretty cool experience for
him, but they didn't bring him back to do
more Santos later.
He just got to play Santos on screen very
briefly for this Avengers post credit scene,
we get our first look at the scepter they
clearly imply that Loki knows there's an infinity
stone inside and that's where it's power comes
from there a lot of fan theories about the
mind stone early on, but it wasn't till years
later in Avengers age of old Tron that they
confirm that they should the she Towery for
the first time we see project Pegasus for
the first time which we later learn was originally
created by Howard Stark in partnership with
shield and Marv L of the Cree to study the
Tesseract trying to explore its potential
for unlimited clean energy and faster than
light travel.
We also learn a lot of modern-day tech like
Iron Man's arc reactors were inspired by the
Tesseract space stone infinity stone energy
and a lot of shields modern-day tech like
the cloaking shields for the Hella carriers
the weaponry is also based on alien kree and
scrolls tech from the 90s.
You also have to keep in mind that Nick fury's
sword space station is also based on Marv
L's original ship which was in orbit in the
90s cloaked from Earth sensors so couple minutes
later in the film when they blow the base
up Nick fury isn't that upset, because he's
already busy building a giant space station
in orbit right now he has his backup site
we need black widow in the new Mark Ruffalo
hold for the first time everything from Incredible
Hulk is still can into the MCU even though
it's a different actor.
The reason why Edward Norton said he parted
ways with Marvel before the Avengers movie
was because he said he wanted to do a darker
version of the whole than Marvel had planned
for the character they'd originally planned
to do a solo hold trilogy with him.
I discussed the plot of what that trilogy
would've been during my Incredible Hulk infinity
saga video so will add a link for that in
the description below, but the final scene
of Edward Norton opening his eyes after meditating
with the green eyes was meant to be a set
up for the famous Hoke line.
That's my secret.
I'm always angry in that now he can actually
control when he becomes the whole when he
jokes about swallowing the Tesseract that's
exactly what goose does back in the 90s and
throws it up like some kind of cosmic hairball
at the end of the Captain Marvel movie.
You also notice that outside to all the agents
waiting for the whole car holding those phase
2 weapons powered by Tesseract energy when
Nick fury meets the shield oversight committee
we see Gideon Malik for the first time more
Marvel phase to set up.
He was later revealed to be the head of Hydra's
operations in America during agents of shield
that she just introduced his grandfather on
that show right before the events of the Captain
America first avenger movie they reference
phase 2 now in the movie is all about the
weaponry that they're developing, but this
is also Marvel's clever way of getting fans
hyped up about the Marvel phase 2 of movies
in real life when Nick fury goes to recruit
Captain America for the Avengers.
He hands of file on the Tesseract it mentions
Mephisto by name and the infinity gems currently
were all hoping to see Mephisto.
One of the upcoming marble phase for movies
or Disney plus series like Dr. strange to
our one division later Marvel would wrecked
con some of this document start calling the
infinity gems the infinity stones and stop
mentioning Mephisto.
Mostly I think because of rights issues with
Fox because of the time they plan to do a
more comic book accurate version of the infinity
gauntlet saga storyline Mephisto is just a
big part of that with Santos.
If you've never read the comic book originally
set like they had big plans for the Mephisto
character in the infinity saga.
But then had to change that later we see the
Stark tower for the first time which would
later become the Avengers Tower and while
everyone is still wondering who bought the
tower during Spider-Man far from home a lot
of people are hoping is Norman Osborne and
Oz Corp. for possible MCU Green goblin or
even the new fantastic four's Baxter building
when Marvel was making the first Avengers
movie, they actually got approval to add the
Oz Corp. building to the New York City skyline.
So you would've seen Oz Corp. right here near
the Avengers Tower.
The reason why it's not in the movie is because
they did get the approval till after the visual
effects were done for this scene, so that
enough time to edit back in 20 peppers joke
about 12% credit strangely gets used again
during guardians in the galaxy's 12% of a
planned joke.
That's probably just a coincidence, though,
but they talk about their relationship foreshadowing
their eventual daughter wearing the Ironman
armor that he built for pepper, implying her
future in the armor as an adult and possible
return in the future Disney plus series.
There was also very big Avengers endgame deleted
seen an alternate ending with Iron Man inside
the soul world of the soul gems speaking to
adult Morgan Stark played by Catherine Langford
from 13 reasons why I pulls and breaks and
they joke about Ironman's life model decoy
currently on agents of shield Colson is actually
a real life model decoy with the memories
of the original Colson who died bringing this
joke around full circle.
They also reference Colson's girlfriend the
cellist they did her as a character on agents
of shield she was played by another fellow
we'd verse alumni Amy Acker he shows Ironman
of bunch of footage from the other Marvel
phase 1 movies including Incredible Hulk Captain
America first avenger in Thor Colson also
sets up the Wizard of Oz Captain America joke
with him not getting any pop-culture references
because he was in the ice later during winter
soldier that she show him writing down a list
of pop-culture stuff that needs to catch up
on the reason why he understood the reference
for Wizard of Oz though is because the movie
came out in 1939 long before he became Captain
America Chris Evans also explained that by
the time we get to Avengers age of all Tron
Captain America is fully caught up on pop-culture
history thanks to the Internet Internet so
helpful Ironman makes his Thor point break
joke, which they brought back in Thor Ragnarok
point break the Hella carrier design itself
here in the bridge is actually meant to mimic
the shield logo in his cool is that is later
we learned that Hydra had so deeply penetrated
all aspects of shield that had they not destroyed.
This Hella carrier during the movie Hydra
probably would've remotely taken control of
it during winter soldier like they did with
the other new Hella carriers with Zola's algorithm
speaking of hail Hydra Sidwell is sitting
at the console near Captain America and Colson
they have a big World War II call back when
the survivor stands up to Loki who demands
they kneel before him and then later, Thor
tells Loki that the throne would ill suited
him.
They paid that joke off during Thor Ragnarok
when it was revealed that Loki had let the
nine realms fall into chaos while pretending
to be Odin because he spent most of his time
goofing off creating place about himself.
You also notice that Odin's ravens are flying
around them during the scene to the real ravens
they're more like advance as guardian magical
creatures the do surveillance for Odin they
the funny line from Captain America about
God not dressing like Thor in Loki, there
is an actual God in the Marvel universe.
He's called the one above all, but who knows
if we'll ever see him in the MCU project they
have their very iconic fight scene, refine
of the Ironman's newer infinity stone base
arc reactor is actually boosted by Thor's
magical lightning later.
They brought this back around during Avengers
endgame when Ironman planned ahead and built
a special receptacle into his new nano armor
to collect even more energy giving him an
even bigger boost the answer the age-old question
what would happen if Thor's hammer it Captain
America shield creates a massive shockwave.
They also brought this back during the exact
same endgame fight when Throws the hammer
at his shield by himself bouncing it off to
hit Santos with even more force Ironman search
wearing his black Sabbath sure is a reference
to the, I am Ironman song from the end of
the first Ironman movie they introduce that
funny gala command scene then brought him
back.
Five seconds later to pay the joke off, we
get our first real big hold Ironman scene
setting up the science prose pairing and setting
up a huge Avengers endgame infinity gauntlet
twist when Ironman tells banner that maybe
the whole committee he became the whole to
save himself during the initial damn accident
as if the whole saved him then they joke I
guess we'll find out if this was all for reason.
If he became the hold for a reason.
Turns out that reason is because the infinity
gauntlet gives off enormous amounts of gamma
energy as he later says it's kind of like
I was made for this Captain America finds
all the phase 2 weapon prototypes with Hydra
logos on them there literally confiscated
red school weapons from World War II so shield
is not being subtle about this in it's all
in service of the eventual winter soldier
hail Hydra twist during marble phase 2 phase
2 weapons phase 2 Hydra takeover plot also
see what they did there.
We are Loki black widow scene where Loki basically
tells us part of the plot of the black widow
movie during marble phase for that movie set
during the past, but he references all the
red on her ledger all the body.
She dropped when she was a black widow when
he calls her Drakov's daughter Drakov is actually
the Russian general in the black widow trailer
who's leading the red room program.
He's also the person who found Natosha is
an orphan and brought her into the program.
Even though he's not her biological father
like red school reveals during Avengers endgame
Drake off is her adoptive father her real
father we would learn is actually named Ivan
and that's them doing a version of her comic
book Backstory where she did have a biological
family but most of them died in a fire.
She survived on the streets until she was
taken in by another Soviet soldier and then
given to the red room program when she was
old enough we have our first classic Ironman
Captain America standoff.
This tension was only heightened by the presence
of the mind stone.
There was always this going on between the
two of them which would boil over during Civil
War Captain America also tells Ironman that
is not the man to make the sacrifice play
here which sets up his sacrifice wielding
the nano infinity gauntlet in Avengers endgame
dying in the process when the hold talks about
putting a bullet in his mouth and the hold
spitting it out.
That's deleted scene from the Incredible Hulk
movie.
They took it out just because it was too dark,
but it was also the same time we saw Captain
America in the MCU setting him up because
his movie came out right after the Incredible
Hulk when banner finally hooks out there's
a funny message nearby on the bulkhead.
This is warning contents under pressure he
tries and fails to pick up Thor's hammer something
that they brought back during Avengers age
of all Tron when almost all the Avengers try
to pick it up.
The Russo's also revealed that Captain America
was always worthy so it's him here pretending
like he can't take it up just as spares for
the heart attack that he's having in the background
watching this is his eyes go wide Loki kills
Colson, but not after he gets in with a couple
sick burns and the destroyer gun that was
designed based on the schematics shield took
from the destroyer after the Thor movie right
after this Jocelyn would bring Colson back
during agents of shield through project Tahiti,
which they explained was Nick fury's backup
plan for resurrecting dead, Avengers should
they ever truly die, but for those you wondering
about black widow coming back after vendors
and game, what about project Tahiti.
They explained that that was just a TV show
thing is not something that the going to do
in the movies at any point most of you probably
recognize Harry Dean Stanton from one of his
many movies in his cameo scene here when Ironman
faces off against Loki and Don's the mark
seven armor you notice in the background of
this scene at the bar there's a picture of
him and pepper that was taken during Ironman
to at the races Ironman quotes the Avengers
comic book catchphrase Earth's mightiest heroes
and even though they have their big Avengers
assemble moment and recite a bunch of comic
book catchphrases they wouldn't let anybody
in any of the movies say Avengers assemble
until Captain America in Avengers endgame
when Ironman tells Loki there's no version
of this where he comes out on top Loki actually
does wind up escaping on top of things with
the Tesseract during Avengers endgame.
That's the Loki that will follow in present
day during the events of the Loki Disney plus
series with the time variance authority her,
like the time copse of the MCU is a lot of
people suspected the reason why Loki's mind
stone doesn't work on Ironman here is because
his arc reactor is based on infinity stone
technology counteracting the cosmic energy
of the mind stone.
We had a big black widow Hawkeye Budapest
reference that's also something were going
to see during marble phase 4 in the black
widow movie displays the beginning of the
black widow trailer is literally Budapest
where she comes to look for Yelena Belova,
but we get a cameo scene from another we verse
alumni Ashley Johnson she also got a longer.
Deleted scene earlier in the movie at her
caf\'e9 near the Avengers tower with Captain
America which also winds up being another
Stan Leecameo scene Captain America's drawing
the Avengers tower.
He was a sketch artist before he became Captain
America.
So even with all of his new powers he still
knows how to draw a really well Ironman even
has one of his sketches from World War II
the monkey that he draws here sitting on his
desk during Captain America Civil War during
the big Avengers assemble moment Or sites
hold signature catchphrase hold smash setting
him loose later when he thrashes Loki, they
actually brought that joke back during Thor
Ragnarok and Avengers endgame to show the
aftermath of this scene where they all come
for him after Ironman takes at the she tower
ship.
He also lands right next to the shawarma place
the gives in the idea for the post credit
scene you this is sure replace that I wanted
to try out when Ironman takes the new through
the portal to destroy thousands fleet.
This exactly how Santos learn who he was,
then mentions him by name during their fight
in Avengers infinity war on Titan.
There's also the same music you when the portal
is closing making it seem like Iron Man is
going to die and not make it back.
They play that exact same music you right
before Ironman snaps the nano infinity gauntlet
in Avengers endgame right when everyone thinks
that all is lost during this ending scene
with all the big montage is the news broadcast
we can another Stan lee cameo scene.
He's playing chess in the park is actually
the same place in the same park from X-Men
the last stand where magneto is playing chess
originally Kevin foggy actually try to include
a young version of magneto in Captain America
first avenger he was going to be one of the
kids that were rounded up and put in the red
schools, camps, but Fox wouldn't approve the
use the character at the time you notice the
A113 reference up in the corner hereto that's
a reference to the famous Cal arts A113 classroom
that the founders of Pixar always sneak into
their movies.
They reveal the plans for the new Avengers
tower currently owned by new management will
probably find out exactly who during Spider-Man
three next year the logos for each of the
Avengers are also meant to be there separate
rooms the labs the facilities designed for
each of their powers the post credit scene
is obvious he the big Santos revealed the
line to court death is a reference to the
infinity gauntlet comic book storyline worth
Enos is literally courting death romantically
by snapping half of all life in the universe
with the infinity gauntlet the closest we've
gotten to the physical embodiment of death
in the MCU is actually the hell a character,
because she's the goddess of death, but she's
not meant to be this version of death than
the final post credit scene is the sure must
scene the story behind this is also very funny
to they literally film.
This post credit scene the night before the
movie premiered in theaters literally the
night before.
The reason why Chris Evans doesn't speak and
just hold his hand it to his face is because
he had to grow a beard for another movie in
they covered his jawline with a really bad
prosthetic but if he spotted any other big
Marvel phase for Easter eggs or other big
Avengers endgame set up moments that I didn't
mention during the video just write them below
in the comments.
So congratulations to the giveaway winner
for the first infinity saga box set a Baez
please message me on the about page my channel
so I can get your contact details everyone
leave your requests for other Marvel bonus
videos in the comments below to so everyone
click here for my new Spider-Man three video
and click here for all my marble infinity
saga rewatch Easter egg videos thank you so
much for watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!